but Roxy and I teamed up with visit
Montana for a trip to one of our
favorite places and Montana has many
diverse winter offerings for the whole
family like skiing and fishing and
snowmobiling and Wildlife tours and of
course there's Yellowstone National Park
oh of course and if you're anything like
me and Drew you love to entertain you've
got to go to Livingston Montana for some
dining and some shopping we are obsessed
take a look at what happened when Drew
and I unexpectedly they had no idea we
were coming we popped into some shops to
surprise the owners in town take a look
all right Rossi we're in Montana we are
in Montana how gorgeous this I love it
here so much and I'm so excited to be
back and so today we're going to go to
fireflies pottery and art studio yeah
we're going to meet Angie and Alex who
own this place they have no idea that
we're coming no in fact I think they
were told we're not coming her size you
want to go surprise them let's go meet
Sam watch out Montana Drew and Ross are
in town
I wish you could be here
um we're super excited to come visit you
guys though and hello
[Music]
[Applause]
we specifically deceived You by telling
you we were not coming here even though
the whole time we were actually planning
on coming here to meet you yeah we lied
a little bit we want to get our hands
dirty can we paint some pottery let's do
it if we were born here yes you guys are
multiple Generations yes my mom Franny
and myself and Alex started the business
so you opened eight years ago I have to
imagine the pandemic had to be tough
that was hard it was kind of like No
One's Gonna come in and paint pottery
while everything was closed so we
decided to kind of make the whole front
a coffee shop we would come in here and
like make our little Margaritas while
the you know everything was shut down
and we were just like
let's do something crazy let's just make
it a coffee shop and I know that the
pandemic was so hard to navigate for
small businesses but then also you know
one positive coming out of it is the
invention of Reinventing and opening up
a coffee shop which is always going to
bring people in definitely it's safe
because we still had some walking
traffic through town we'd like to pay
for this and leave a five thousand
dollar tip to say thank you for
everything no you are not oh yes and I'm
going to double that so that's ten
thousand no you're not I
associated with something positive
[Laughter]
we've just been so inspired by your
story
[Applause]
thank you so much and we're just I'm an
ugly prior you guys listen you had
really difficult obstacles to face and I
know it's not easy and that's why we
want to contribute you are a total
inspiration thank you we are going to
meet Rob and Dale they own a fly fishing
shop here in town and it is a
institution yeah it's been here for like
85 years yeah and they do so much for
the community and they have no idea
we're gonna pop in well let's go in come
on guys welcome to Dan Bailey's
Livingston Montana
[Music]
we're really glad we could be featured
on the show we love you love you we love
you too
thank you nice to meet you you guys have
been here for a long time right yeah
yeah how long Dan Bailey's been here
since 1938. I'm not quite that old
um but I was born here Rob was born here
most of our staff is from moving to
Montana we're just carrying on the damn
Bailey Legacy I have to say as a mom I
was really blown away also by your
summer camp program how did you start
that program I hope we get back to the
community is core to as part of our
foundation here it's not just about
selling things you know we want to sell
the experience and we want to share that
with other people we live in this
beautiful place you know we we have a
very strong Community here can I ask a
question and it's
okay ready
hey
do I look pretty good
turns out all I'm fishing for is a
compliment beautiful we're gonna be
tying a woolly bugger today excuse me I
rarely woolly bugger on the first day
wooly bugger is a is a classic Montana
Fly pattern if you wrap over the shank
of the hook Yep this is where the
Magic's gonna happen this is called
Chenille and I didn't know you come to
Montana and be working with feather boas
and Chenille this is I feel like I'm
gonna fit right in here yeah yeah side
by side let's look at mine versus Drews
I think we really nailed it I think we
complement each other like we do in life
wow I've got a big story to tell my
family tonight we get to take your
beautiful place of business that's been
so important to this community and as a
mom I see the way that you take care of
families it's also one little thing we'd
like to do yeah we'd love to support
your store with a five thousand dollar
donation but I'm gonna match that so
it's actually ten thousand dollars it's
something we wanted to do for you guys
in awe and inspiration of what you teach
people on how to live and how to be and
how to do and how to give yeah I'm Blown
Away you teach us and you inspire us can
we take a selfie guys oh yes please come
on get in here one two three
[Applause]
Montana has such a rich history these
cool shops small businesses I mean it is
just such a wonderful place I know we
fell in love with Montana and up next
don't miss the two of us driving a sled
full of dogs through the snow mush mush
mush we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]